[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
a few beer five of us crack
Republican party is and there's no
better example of all foam no beer than
Ted can [__] cruise obviously what a
phony what a fraud
the Republican party is and again it's
you know the charade of him drinking
Shiner Bock beer
is just a prime example of how we are at
the intersection of WrestleMania and
real life
I've been saying it for a long time
of course you know this you know that
these people are a [__] are just [__]
phonies
what of what a piece of trash Ted Cruz
is I would like to start there
let's just talk about what a piece of
trash he is
such a [__] phony that when there a
couple years ago when there was a huge
winter storm that basically shut off the
power to Texas people were freezing to
death Ted Cruz didn't fly to Washington
he didn't fly to a city there in Texas
to help
he went to Cancun with his family and
then tried to say no no no no no no no
no no
I I just I just went down there to make
sure they got into the hotel okay
they left their dog
at the house while it was freezing do
you remember this
the ironic part about the dog is the
dog's name is snowflake I'm not making
that [__] [__] up the dog's name
is snowflake
and Ted Cruz left the dog in the house
during the winter storm because there
the power grid in Texas went down
because we have in-app politicians like
Ted Cruz and Greg Abbott in power
and the [__] goes on new he's
been he's been acting like he's been
acting like he likes beer for several
weeks now
Ted Cruz doesn't like beer you can't I
just just like Ted Cruz never wore a
beard before
until he's got this shitty ass wish.com
wolverine beard
he doesn't drink beer now he's really
upset
that the American Board of alcoholism
has said look it's probably a good idea
for your health if you don't drink over
two beers and they're like ah ow
oppression
oh my God an association that
he's on alcoholism
suggest suggest being the main word
that we can't drink more than two beers
listen you [__] idiot
Ted Cruz no one is oppressing you
you [__] shitbox
but you know
he's been talking about how Bud Light is
a queer beer and he's gonna investigate
we're gonna investigate Bud Light that's
what he's been saying we're gonna invest
investigate Bud Light for pedophileism
what well see Dylan Mulvaney uh she she
uh she she has an audience and Bud Light
paid her
to drink beer on one video and somehow
this is Bud Light advertising to
children get the [__] out of here Ted
Cruz
you don't really believe that [__]
Ted Cruz does not believe this stuff
just like Ted Cruz doesn't drink beer
Ted Cruz has probably never had two
beers in one setting that [__] that
[__] phony
no [__] way to has Ted Cruz ever
drank two beers in one sitting if you
watch him drink this Shiner Bock beer
on camera of course I freeze I freeze
the uh the image of him trying to
swallow it
and it it looks like it looks like when
Ben Shapiro is in the room with his wife
and his wife is trying to get kind of
horny you know what I mean gross
that's what it looks like when Ted Cruz
is trying to swallow the Shiner Bock
beer now I don't know if it tastes like
[__] I've never really had Shiner Bock
Beer apparently it's a beer from Texas
and I've never had it I don't know
I drink I drink the old good old queer
beer
Bud Light natural light that's that's
what I drink
and not because not because Dylan
Mulvaney advertised it it's just because
that's always what I've drank
I'm gonna tell you I like watered down
beer
I like I like my beer to taste like
water okay just the way I like it
Ted Cruz
is just like any other Republican and
again I don't want to make it feel like
Ted Cruz is an outlier here in this
little charade that he did about the
drinking of the beer and I know you're
like why is this a story why is this
your lead story well number one I was
drinking last night not beer Jaeger as I
normally do so I'm a little late to the
game this morning and honestly I didn't
look at any news stories I didn't listen
to the news this morning I read a few
things on Twitter
I know that the proud boys oh my God
speaking of Ted Cruz
speaking of Ted Ted Cruz loves proud
boys ah Ted Cruz is taking pictures of
Enrique tario ah yeah he loves the proud
boys and The Oath Keepers
and yesterday we know that the uh the
sentencing for Enrique tario was
postponed because the judge was sick but
this morning
they're starting to uh sentence
the proud boys and The Oath Keepers
again
uh it looks like and if I I haven't I
was getting the show ready so I don't
know if it's dropped yet
but it looks like some of these
seditious [__] who tried to
overturn our vote in the name of Donald
Trump at the direction it seems
of Donald Trump
seems like they're going to spend a long
time in federal prison
rap row
rut row
could it be that Ted Cruz is trying to
distract us with this beer thing
oh man I'm down here in Texas and I
drink beer
and Sean or Bach is my beer and the
reason why Shiner Bock is my beer is
because I went and toured the brewery
it's like Ted Cruz thinks he knows
everything about beer because he walked
into a brewery
oh my God
but this is the Republican party they
are fake they're phony
now we see through it right
like you I'm gonna show you the video
here in a little bit I'm gonna show you
the video of Ted Cruz acting and
pretending like he likes to drink beer
and the best part about it isn't even
Ted Cruz pretending he likes to drink
the beer it's all the guys in the
background that are cute standing there
holding the beer
and then they get the cue from Ted Cruz
and they all drink the beer at the same
time
[Music]
oh you [__] phony ass posers oh my
God have you watched the video of Dylan
Mulvaney drink Bud Light
have you seen it
when Dylan move in and we showed it
we've shown it on the show when when you
watch that video that Bud Light paid for
on her Instagram when she cracks open
the beer and takes a drink of the Bud
Light you can tell Dylan is not drinking
Bud Light that much
right you just can tell that
she hadn't drank Bud Light that much
that it was a paid ad to have that beer
in that Instagram
because it was
the funny part is is that that whole
Instagram was staged
and then
these these [__] chuckleheads they
think they're so manly
they think they're masculinity
is oozing over so much that when they
staged their beer drinking it's not the
same listen Ted Cruz and all the [__]
little cucks behind you
all those [__] fat ass
[__] white old dudes
are cucks you're [__] cuts and your
[__] props you pieces of trash
every single [__] one of them and it
would be a shame if the internet found
out who these people were who posed for
this beer drinking little charade oh
it'd be a horrible thing
you're a horrible thing
I'm gonna play the video everyone's
asking to play I'm gonna play the video
don't worry we're gonna watch the
[__] video
it's hilarious
but this is a lesson in why why you
should not be voting Republican ever
everything they say because he talks
about [__] ceiling fans in this thing
he's talking about how the Biden
Administration wants to get rid of beer
and ceiling fans shut the [__] up Ted
Cruz he's like oh yeah look we need
ceiling fans here in Texas it's hot yep
[__] it's hot in Texas maybe
what you should be doing instead of
pretending to like beer and [__] have
some sort of little spear skit to make
you feel manly maybe what you should do
Ted Cruz
is you should be working on making sure
that Texas power grid is not shut down
so you can run the [__] AC and the
goddamn ceiling fans because it's so
[__] hot because Republicans have
decided that climate change is a fraud
you [__] you [__] pieces of
garbage
this is what they do this is what they
do
folks
they stage fake ass [__] to pretend that
they're manly so that you thought yeah
he's uh Ted Cruz real manly he drinks
China Bach I mean he it looks like I
mean
real really honestly I would I would
imagine
Ted Cruz
likes a lot a lot a lot more things in
his mouth
and Shiner Bach
just saying you know this is a guy who
cut to Trump
called his [__] wife ugly
he called his [__] wife ugly and Ted
Cruz I don't you ever go to Erica my
wife ugly or out
I'll I'll call your beer queer is what
I'll do
he did nothing
matter of fact he did the opposite
when it came time to get on his knees
for Donald Trump to put his Cheeto dust
knee pads on Ted Cruz did it
oh and he got a big Taste of Cheeto in
his mouth for damn sure I don't know if
I don't know if he prefers the taste of
Cheeto over shinerbach but it sure does
seem like it boy he deep throated that
Cheeto Cheeto
I mean it's you know it's not the it's
not the like the Puffs it's like the
little bitty you know I'm talking about
a little bitty crunchy ones that are in
the bottom of the bag
I think he prefers those Cheetos way
over Shadow Shiner Bock
but this is the stuff that I try to show
you every day of why this stuff is all
[__] it's all phony even Donald
Trump's stupid [__] videos he's done
like 42 videos in the last two days
whining bitching and moaning I'm gonna
show you one of these videos today and
it's it's [__] real it's not AI
the [__] is [__] real
it's crazy we showed you one yesterday
this guy has lost his [__] mind
but Diddy or is he just pretending
it feels like it feels like they're just
pretending
it feels like a really bad reality TV
show
we're Republicans
are in this [__] alternate reality of
Americans like anyone gives two shits
rather Ted Cruz can drink beer or not
does anyone care no even they went so
far to Stage this thing that even Eric
Bolin
the host of the Newsmax interview that
they were interviewing Ted Cruz
had a non-alcoholic beer ready to go
they had planned the whole thing
for this little one clip and they
thought it's a total burn and they're
owning the libs
folks they're losing badly
they're losing badly
now the only way that we actually see
some
substantive losses for them is for you
to engage in your democracy
for us to fight this fight at The Ballot
Box
Ted Cruz has gotta go he's got to go
it's ridiculous how how [__]
ridiculous is it that this guy is not
only a United States Senator but he's a
United States senator for one of the
most highly heavily populated states in
this country
this guy represents a ton of people in
the Senate and he's not representing
them
he's doing podcast and writing beer
skits for Newsmax
that's what he's doing
it's [__] crazy ass [__]
and of course the right's like yeah go
get him Ted what
if you watch it and you're not cringing
dude you're [__] brainwashed if you
watch this video because it
again it's just an exclamation point on
what what is wrong with the Republican
party and why they're already dead
because that's really the thing here I
mean that's really the the that's really
the story it's not the Ted Cruz is
pretending to drink beer that he likes
or that he's a total [__] fraud and a
phony he doesn't represent anyone in
Texas he's an elected official who
doesn't who doesn't do government he
just a hundred percent does reality TV
and that's what it is for most of these
[__] Matt gatz Marjorie Taylor green
Lauren bobert Jim Jordan Jim Comer Jesus
Christ Jim Comer this morning
on Fox News they're like so I know it
was last night on Hannity even better
so you have the evidence oh yeah pretty
sure pretty sure we have the evidence
haven't they been saying this for the
last six months when are they gonna show
us this evidence that they believe they
have
huh or or is that all a beer skit too
you remember the [__] Kavanaugh beer
skit don't you
huh there was a Kavanaugh beer skit
we find out this morning we find out
this morning that Heartland Hitler
has been paying even more trips for
Clarence Thomas
so Clarence Thomas has been pretending
to be a Supreme Court Justice this whole
time when he's bought and paid for
he's a Lackey for Harlan Hitler
these people are not serious
these people should not be anywhere near
our government because it's our
government
and we can do something about it
you have the power of the ballot
you have the power of your voice
that's what it that is what the
intention is to use it
your ballot and your voice
we stand around and just continue to let
these [__] run rough shot over
us and pretend on on Newsmax to drink
beer so they can own the libs on the Bud
Light thing again what the [__] are you
what the [__] are you doing for Texas
Ted Cruz huh every [__] Texan who
watches this clip should be so [__]
pissed off
just [__] livid
but folks they're not because that
really is the problem that we have and
I've been telling you about it
that's why Donald Trump's gonna be their
nominee it's a cult
it's a cult
the cult sees this video and they're
like yeah only him Libs
as if that does anything for them
absolutely anything
to own the libs as if this hasn't
backfired over and over and over again
why do you think
why do you think there was no Red Wave
in 2022
the reason why the reason why Donald
Trump
the reason why Donald Trump lost in 2020
and there was no Red Wave in 2022 is
because they're [__] phonies
and the majority of the country sees
through this [__]
the problem is is most people vote on
affiliation and we still have
we still have
a huge portion of the country
who is voting on affiliation and the
cult members
who make up the Republican voting block
that's right there's two Styles a voting
block
for the Republican Party these days
there's the Cults there's the cult
members who were [__] delusional
deranged
convinced convinced that there's a
blood-second cabal and JFK Jr is going
to come back and Crown Donald Trump King
they can't see that the election fraud
comes from the right
the only election fraud that we've been
able to unearth the last two years is a
bunch of [__] Republicans
voting two three times for Donald Trump
sometimes killing their [__] family
members to go vote for him like in
Pennsylvania
the highest concentrated
voter fraud in America is at The
Villages in Florida south Florida
and they all voted for Trump
they can't see it
because they're blinded by delusion and
lies and then you add the other part of
the Republican Party
who who are just like cult members liked
right it's kind of like it's kind of
like Budweiser you know if you want to
do the whole beer thing it's kind of
like Budweiser which in my neck of the
woods we call a diesel right that's what
you call Diesel and then you got Bud
Light
you got the regular
right
Bud Lights the I know it seems backwards
like you'd have Budweiser would be
regular and light would be you know but
that's not how it is Budweiser's diesel
and then Bud Light is regular
I mean I live in Missouri we live in the
Budweiser beer state
frankly I prefer natural light it's the
same as Bud Light the same as Michelob
Ultra it's just [__] way cheaper I'm
a cheap [__]
it's the way it is
but then you but you have you have
Budweiser which is diesel which is the
Maga cult man oh man they'll believe
anything you [__] tell them they'll
be believe about [__] what was that
one guy talking about the other day
borgs like the vaccine makes you
non-human and [__] they'll believe all
kinds of weird ass [__] all kinds of RFK
Jr
[__] chewing on type [__]
and then and then you have then you have
the Bud Lights
of the Republican party right they're
really watered down
but they're still Budweiser I mean it's
still but it is really watered down you
know what I mean
they're still going to vote Republican
because they're you know they're part of
the cult
this is a watered-down version of The
Cult it's the old style cult more you
know more tolerable
for people who don't want to go down the
kiwanon road
and Drake the full-on Budweiser diesel
nah
but that's the trouble that we have and
that's what we're fighting
that's why we all have to engage we all
have to get out there and do our part
and do what we can
I mean I sit here in front of the
microphone two hours a day yelling and
screaming showing you these stories
giving you the the narrative
trying to trying to give you the
cathartic release that you need but also
point you in the direction
and use your strategic outrage to aim it
at your democracy to save it
with the truth
the cold hard truth
you guys you guys are really you know I
thought a lot of people would be mad
this week about some of the the truth
that I've been dropping but you know you
guys you guys you guys see it this
audience definitely sees
that the truth no matter how much we
don't like it and we don't want it to be
the truth
you guys get it that she got it you
gotta get with the truth and then get
with get with getting to saving
democracy
because we do have to save it it's not
preserving it at this point hopefully in
the next 15 20 years we can just
continue to do the work to preserve
democracy now I have to save it from
these [__] fascist bastards
these pretend ass [__] these
frauds like Ted Cruz
maybe one of these days the truth will
be oh yeah we can just preserve the [__]
but it's gonna be a while until then
because as long as long as they get the
cult to believe this trash that is in
this little clip about the beer
as long as we they can still convince
people that that shit's real
we gotta fight
you're not gonna believe this I know
everyone wants to see this clip
and I'm gonna show it to you when we
come back from the break
I'm gonna show you this clip of Ted Cruz
he believed this [__]
they're watching they're like yeah Ted
Cruz is the manly manly man oh yeah he's
he's
totally he totally's got one of them big
wenises
it's ridiculous and it's all it's all I
mean it's all for the Newsmax audience
all of it
which is
probably 70 percent white old men
who don't want women to have abortions
want them to be in the kitchen barefoot
making them a goddamn meal they don't
need no [__] jobs and they should be
boating either it's probably
that's probably who they're targeting I
mean when you see the video you'll know
that a lot of people are saying I'm
teasing you about to be I'm not teasing
you about that I mean okay a little bit
what I'm I very rarely show any kind of
media in the first 30 minutes
it's just me yelling and screaming
that's intentional
so like you're like you're [__] tease
a lot of you are saying Bud light's
gross hey ease up ease up on some
people's preferences I mean Ted Cruz
pretends to like Shiner buck
you know different people like different
taste Ted Cruz again we've already
determined loves the taste of Cheeto in
his mouth now if you don't like the
taste of Cheeto in your mouth
you're going to want to follow this show
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube subscribe now it's [__]
free hit the Subscribe button and it's
also free to like it and if you don't
like it it's free to dislike it too go
ahead and do that then cost you a single
dime now for all the other links to
follow us everywhere go to
thetonymichaels.com that's right go to
thetonymichaels.com you can send a venmo
chat there if you want your chat to
appear on screen today just get in the
venmo chat go to the Tony michaels.com
you'll find the link there follow us on
Facebook
follow us on Twitch it's free there
follow us on Twitter the threads
everywhere you can follow us and also
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify and Google you can find those
links on leetonymichaels.com as well
grab you some merch too if you want if
you want it helps out it helps the show
or there's a tip jar there on the Tony
michaels.com don't go anywhere I mean
unless you're gonna go over the website
go over the website when we come back
I'll show you this clip of Cancun Cruise
pretending to like beer what a [__]
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
and back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
a lot of you um
are questioning a word that I use Venus
if you if you don't think
Ted Cruz identifies
his genitalia is a wenis all right I
almost guarantee it damn guarantee it
almost guarantee it you never heard that
before wenis
oh boy how long how much longer should I
go before I show you this clip or should
we just get into it just get into the
Ted Cruz clip
um oh [__] listen I I here's the thing
when I'm doing this show I've got a lot
of screens up here
I got a lot of screens going that's why
when you see me like [__] back and
forth or looking up here looking over
here it's because I got like a command
center going here you know what I mean
maybe I'll show you games behind the
scenes one of these days of what it
looks like when I'm doing the show but I
mean I've got I've got like the venmo
chat up in case someone does a venmo
chant it's there we've got we've got the
Discord up you got to go you got to go
get in the Discord oh my God you should
have seen all the wenis memes the minute
I was talking about Ted Cruz
um
fellatio with a Cheeto and oh boy they
were getting wild over there
uh they were getting wild over there so
if you want to get into the uh the
Discord chat it's where the chat party
never stops but the unique part about it
is is that it actually
um they can put you can put memes in
there but video in there gifts so it's
kind of unique in that way so go to the
Discord I put the the link in the chat
right there
um but
I I'm always looking and I'm always
trying to keep track of if there's any
stories going right or if anyone's
sending me messages I'm really trying to
you know just pay attention to
everything
and it's a lot sometimes especially when
I'm trying to keep my train of thought
and not have a single pause did you
notice that when I do the show there's
very few pauses
this is a two hour show every day we
could do probably five we should be
doing three
for sure for the content that we have we
really should be doing three we missed
so much [__]
on this show
to cover
but what are you gonna do right
what are you gonna do three hours takes
a lot
here's the thing
I'm sitting here and there's all of a
sudden a video of Charlie Kirk and I'm
popping up on the screen
um and and I'm trying to read and think
and then keep my train of thought to
figure out maybe this is a video that we
need to watch like right now we can't we
can't wait
we can't wait and I it's put out by
right wing watch so I'm sure
I'm sure that this whatever Charlie Kirk
is saying about the founding fathers in
this
is probably just uh you know
absolute Peak Alpha cook type [__]
um it normally is again it's all it's
all [__] [__] they don't believe
any of this [__] they don't believe any
of this [__] Charlie Kirk Ted Cruz
Donald Trump they don't believe any of
this stuff they're just trying their
damnedest to get other [__]
other stupid bastards to to believe this
[__] that's all it is
Alex Jones was the king of this
speaking of Alex Jones he was brought up
in the sentencing uh today of the in the
condition uh
seditious conspiracy sorry I'm getting
words mixed around it must still be the
Jaeger
thing
like Alex Jones never believed any of
that [__]
he didn't believe any of that [__] was
all it's all a [__] show it's not
real there's not they don't believe he
doesn't believe that there's gay frogs
or that there's Chemtrails he's trying
to get other dumb [__] to
believe that [__] because honestly he
knows if he could convince these people
that there's gay frogs and chemtrails he
can definitely convince them to give him
their money
for [__] boner pills and and muscle
supplements I'm not [__] you that's
mainly what [__] Alex Jones sells is
boner pills and muscle supplements I
wonder what it could be about boner
pills and muscle supplements that these
people [__]
that they that they believe this [__]
what is it what what group and what
demographic
would a hundred percent be so [__]
stupid to buy a bunch of boner pills and
muscle supplements from someone like
Alex Jones who could you pinpoint that
it would be
I'm I'm sure Alex Jones's audience is
made up of 90 of suburban white women
right it really seems like it with the
[__] that he sells the [__] out of here
it's a bunch of old white dudes
it's a bunch of old delusional white
dudes who want to feel oppressed
who want to feel oppressed
so it makes them feel good about
oppressing others
just like Charlie Kirk and Ted Cruz
pretending to be oppressed oh man Dave
I'm a God can you believe Bud Light
Bud Light did that to us white fragile
men they had Dylan Mulvaney did an ad on
Instagram
oh my God and it took our manhood away
the [__] out of here man
I told you the story here and it's a
couple months ago I was at a live event
I walked into a bar it's like a street
event they had a band playing and I
walked into a bar and I ordered a Bud
Light and this [__] fragile white
dude behind me he said oh there's a
skirt come with that beer and I turned
around and said what are you talking
about he said oh well that's that's one
of them gay beers I said you think beer
makes you gay
and he's like well I just I just don't
like the queers
that's basically what he said I don't
know the exact words but and I said oh
yeah you don't so I took a big Swig of
the Bud Light and I said yep totally
wants me to makes me want to [__] all
the dudes in this bar
you should have seen the Tariff the
terror on his face the terror because I
mean the frankly what he what he's meant
was is I'm gay and I don't want anyone
to know I'm gay because I drink beer
because I hate gay people I self-hate
myself I'm closeted and I hate myself
because I'm so scared that all my all my
other straight closeted gay friends who
pretend to hate gay people because
they're just projecting
I oh man they'll judge the [__] out of
me and then they'll know I'm gay that's
what the [__] he's saying
they're terrified terrified of their own
shadow
they're such [__] cuts
it's like they've never been out in
public before some [__] you know a lot
of people are like you know what we
gotta stop we gotta stop spanking kids
and I'm I'm gonna tell you man since we
started that stuff
look what's happened to uh to our world
these people believe some crazy ass [__]
I'm just saying I'm not advocating for
it I'm just saying I don't think there's
any kind of connection maybe I don't
know do you want to watch this Ted Cruz
video you're like Tony God damn it it's
been you've been back for almost 10
minutes you told us you'd play this
[__] video of Ted Cruz and play the
goddamn video that's on Newsmax it's on
Eric Boland show
hell here he is Ted Cruz it's a great
Freeze Frame here
um I can't even believe you have to put
the word senator in front of this guy's
name honestly that's a [__] crime
against humanity isn't it that we gotta
put the word senator in front of Ted
Cruz's name
now if you notice here in the
oh my God you don't notice it at first
but I'm gonna point it out to you look
at the background there
they dim the lights in the background
because they got the the light on Ted
Cruz but they didn't even light the guys
up in the background
I don't know why
but it's a bunch of old fat white dudes
and button snap shirts and Feed Store
hats there's a few cowboy hats because
they're in Texas but it's a bunch of
[__] old white dudes old fat white
dudes
cucks
in Feed Store hands and they're old I
got I mean there's one guy in there he
might he might be in his 30s he might be
maybe this guy back here look this guy
back here he might be in his 30s
the rest of these guys are older than
Ted Cruz
come on and this is the representation
because you know it's a diverse crowd
standing there behind Ted Cruz
and they're all they're all posing with
their shitty Shiner Bock beer
none of them none of them drink this
[__] beer they all they all drink
they all drink Bud Light or some version
of Bud Light that's what they drink
because it's [__] cheap
so this idea that these [__] idiots
behind here
actually actually drink shinerbach beer
on a regular basis that's all [__]
get the [__] out of here
no way can you convince me that these
old fat beer guts back here are all
shinerbach
bull [__] [__]
Chrissy here on Facebook says is this at
a beer belly contest exactly
I mean and that's what they did to like
what we want is we want old white men
with beer Millies in this video with Ted
Cruz and they set this up
I mean this isn't this is all all of the
the whole thing is staged
and it's not like stage like Newsmax is
like hey Ted Cruz is going to be on
tonight it'll be interesting to see what
he says now
nope
cause Eric Boland The Host
he has a beer and it's [__] hilarious
when Eric ball I'm gonna show it to you
when Eric Bowman
you're like Tony's played a [__] clip
oh [__] you like how I hang it there
just hang it you know what I mean just
hang it huh
that's a tactic it really is it truly is
a tactic to to keep you watching because
you're like oh you're gonna show it and
I'm probably gonna dump about 100 people
off the audience because like [__] you
Tony you're dead now you're just [__]
with us and Counting him but here's
here's the let's play the first part of
the clip where Ted Cruz
um because at first you don't think it's
staged
it's just a bunch of old white dudes
hanging out weirdly behind dead Creek
because this is how white dudes hang out
right don't you know that when a guy's
on camera they they get behind him and
they they hold their beer and stare into
the camera like a deer in headlights
let's watch
now done that for new construction
they're trying to go after and regulate
ceiling fans I got to tell you it's hot
in Texas we don't want to get rid of our
ceiling fans and now the agated all
right so there's so there's the first
part of it right and he's talking about
ceiling he starts off by ceiling fans
but what he needs to do
it's just gotta go from ceiling fans
right dividing Administration outlawing
ceiling fan which is not a thing it's
not a thing
it's not actually ceiling fans are good
did you know that ceiling fans are good
ceiling fans are good
if they're you know manufactured
properly if they're installed properly
if they're used properly
they actually can save you a lot of
energy they can they're a great energy
saver especially if you have a very
efficient one ceiling fan because it
costs money to run a fan I mean it's
electric Ted Cruz wouldn't know that
because the power Grid's always down in
Texas because Republicans run Texas he
wouldn't know anything about electric
and how much it costs because they don't
have electric down there there's no
[__] power grid
I mean what do you want for me don't
don't come after me
but here here he's he got to go from
ceiling fans to queer beer watch his
transition here oh man it's magnificent
these idiots have come out and said
drink two beers a week that's their
guideline well I gotta tell you if they
want us to drink two beers a week Frank
okay so he's saying the American Board
of alcoholism is gonna ban ceiling fans
and they're telling you you can only
drink two beers that's not what he's
saying he's lying
that's right I said it Ted Cruz is a
[__] liar hmm
who'da guessed it
he's a republican that's that should
give it away immediately that he's a
[__] liar
but here's the thing he's conflating
what a study is on ceiling fans
and what a study from an entirely
different organization an entirely
different institution not the government
not Joe Biden Joe Biden doesn't have a
gasoline button on his desk he doesn't
have a ceiling fan button on his desk
and he doesn't have a beer but he might
have a beer button on his desk
I know I bet Joe Biden has a beer button
you know Donald Trump had Diet Coke that
[__] that [__] loser that [__]
cuck
I mean a lot of you might drink Diet
Coke but Diet Coke [__] I'm just gonna
say it I'm probably never gonna get
sponsored by Coke so I can say that
[__] Diet Coke is [__] it tastes like
[__] it doesn't tastes like Coke it
doesn't
even Diet Pepsi is [__] folks diet soda
in general is garbage it's it's it's
getting up there to be almost as much
trash
as half Republicans but I digress from
that
but Joe Biden does not have a ceiling
fan button on his desk Joe Biden's not
like you know what here's what we're
gonna do here's we're gonna make
everyone in the country take down their
ceiling fans because we're woke
what
it's a really stupid [__] and then he's
like oh yeah we're we're gonna do what
we're gonna do for in the name of wokism
is make sure people only drink two beers
listen you stupid [__] woke people
drink way more beer way more beer
than the non-woke
they do way more [__] beer oh [__]
liberals drink way more [__] beer
than conservatives would ever [__]
dream of beer hurts their sensitive
little feelings if you want to know the
honest truth because really the the
pictures in this [__] of these guys
with these beer guts it's not beer guts
those are potato chip guts
these guys eat way too many [__] bags
of Doritos
okay that's what the problem is here
this idea when he's conflating
ceiling fans and beer right that's how
he's trying to tie it together it's a
total [__] lie total [__] [__]
no one's telling anyone you can't have
two beers they're just like hey
and for your health you probably don't
want to drink more than a couple beers a
week or you'll look like these fat
[__] in this picture Okay this
prime example prime example of why you
probably shouldn't eat snack food a lot
and you probably shouldn't [__] drink
a lot of beer you're gonna look like
these fat [__]
and you know you're probably gonna have
cardiac problems because you're so
goddamn heavy oh Tony you're body
shaming people
look if you eat a lot of snack food and
beer trust me I know you're gonna get a
little heavy it's gonna happen I'm not
saying that's bad if you like the beer
drink the [__] beer if you like the
potato chips eat the [__] potato
chips Ted no one's telling you not to
drink beer or don't eat potato chips all
they're saying is hey it's probably not
a good idea when it's your health
it's probably not a good idea that's
your health
so
let's go on let's see how he ties
ceiling fans and beer let's see how he
makes it to queer did you notice though
when he when he has okay he didn't even
have an open beer
like they didn't even they didn't think
far enough head when Ted Cruz looks over
here at the beer he's like oh [__] it's
not even open they didn't open my beer
they didn't take the cap off of it
how funny would it have been if Shiner
Bach wasn't a Twist Off oh my God that
would have been [__] hilarious
oh man shinerbach I'm disappointed in
you at this point that would have been a
hell of a Twist wouldn't it he goes to
twist it off and he can't all right but
watch watch when he grabs his beer he's
really [__] mad that they didn't
twist off the cat because he's not
drinking beer
he wasn't drinking beer they set the
beer for them for just this just this
clip there
to drink two beers a week Frank
now look look at all the guys behind him
because all these fat [__]
behind him were told when Ted Cruz says
when Ted Cruz says they can kiss my ass
that's when every single one of you
drinks beer at the exact same time
[Laughter]
oh my [__] god and the the best part
about this is there's a bunch of [__]
old ass white men [__] cucks out
there they don't wouldn't know
masculinity if it's sat on their face
looking at this going yeah this is so
look at all these guys in the background
they look like me
as they pretend to like Shiner Bock and
they all drink a sip of beer
all at the same exact time Jesus [__]
Christ don't give it away now watch Ted
Cruz's face after he takes one little
Swig of this Shiner buck and tell me if
he if it looks like this guy drinks much
beer
no okay
um here's the face right
there that's where I froze it it's on
the thumbnail too
oh [__] that Beer's [__] [__]
gross
you know that's what he said after this
guy he [__] beer
I I like
I like wine coolers why can't why can't
we have protests with wine coolers you
know that's what he's doing right
oh yeah oh yeah Ted Cruz definitely
likes wine coolers way more than he
likes beer
way more any and that's probably why why
he pretends to drink Shiner back here
and he's so disgusted by it when he puts
it to his lips
is that he's more of a wine cooler type
guy
more of a wine cooler type guy
[Laughter]
some people are trashing seltzers hey
there's nothing wrong with seltzers
they're good wine coolers are good too
I'm not saying I don't like a wine
cooler easy easy
easy I'm just saying Ted Cruz probably
questions his sexuality when he enjoys a
wine cooler because they're they're [__]
they're [__] Hucks
they don't know what masculine
masculinity is not tied to the your food
and drink preference
or the label on your beard they don't
have any clue they don't know that
watch this this is hilarious what Eric
Boland does the host why
and tell me that tell me that this
wasn't staged I mean he had it ready
once okay
um Senator I uh I brought a beer to
drink with you I'll drink this
non-alcoholic beer with you because I'm
not allowed to drink on camera but
[Laughter]
I'm sorry I can't when I first saw this
clip I started laughing I couldn't stop
and I still can't help it what a [__]
bunch of [__]
oh I'm I'm
gonna enjoy a beer with you sir oh it
just so happens look looky here oh looky
a non-alcoholic beer in in a beer are
you [__] me
could somewhere somewhere in Eric
bolin's contract
It's gotta say it's got It's gotta say
somewhere in airborne's contract it's
got to say that he can't drink beer on
screen
because it has alcohol in it
now you notice if we go back and you
notice when he picks up this beer Eric
Bowen this thing doesn't have a label on
it
this thing doesn't have a label on it I
mean it's got a back label on it but
it's kind of hard to tell I mean there's
only so many in a beers out there right
so we could probably sniff out which
which [__] beer this is
But Eric Bolling is claiming this is an
in a beer and again he's he doesn't
drink beer that much either
especially in a beer you didn't drink
beer
oh man
don't don't someone put wenises in the
place of these beers please don't do
that please do not do that with your
creative art
um here's and Ted Cruz look at his face
here did he take another drink of this
beer or is there anyone else behind him
that takes a drink of this beer let's go
back and let's see they take the one
drink uh yeah they all drink it together
all right and then they're all standing
there they don't want to drink this beer
it's [__] this is not a good commercial
for Shiner Bock right
at all
at all it's not it's it's not a good
commercial for shinerbach but let's
let's listen to what Eric Bolens is
about the n a beer and then see how Ted
Cruz
Ted Cruz is like uh he just watched
non-alcoholic beer with you because I'm
not allowed to drink on camera but oh my
god
well look I gotta say have you ever I'll
have a sit a brand do more damn to
itself than Bud Light which would what
how in the [__] did Ted Cruz go from
Eric Bolin being like yeah since we
staged this whole thing and I can't
drink alcohol on screen I got an in a
beer here ready I actually had the cap
off of mine because I'm not a [__] I
wanted people to think I was actually
drinking it and then he he says I'll
take a sip
oh my God
oh have you ever have you ever talked to
a real beard a Beer Drinker like someone
who drinks a lot of [__] beer not not
like recreationally I'm like it's a
[__] Hobby
there are there are people out there
that drink beer and that's their [__]
you know some people you know some
people do like woodworking
some people golf
some people drink [__] beer
that's what they [__] do as a hobby
I when I was a teenager I worked for one
I worked for a guy you had a farm
I was a farm and on his farm
and he had he had two two [__]
refrigerators one in the garage at the
house and one down at the [__]
machine [__] and that [__]
refrigerator was packed packed full of
Bud Light packed full of Bud Light it
always had [__] Bud Light in it of
course I was you know 13 14 years old I
definitely didn't sneak any no never
would have done that never never never
got drunk while I was working as a farm
hand
but I've met real [__] beer drinkers
real [__] beer drinkers who drink
from from before lunch until they
[__] pass out at night
real [__] beer drinkers
and I've never
in my life heard a real Beer Drinker say
I'm just gonna have a sip
these people are such [__] phonies
they don't they really don't the people
who are watching this [__] don't even
know that these people don't even
[__] uh they don't even associate
with them they have no idea who they are
they don't know they don't know middle
and lower class Americans they don't
even know real white people if you want
to know the God's honest truth Eric
Boland probably doesn't know [__] about
[__] about being a real white person not
a [__] thing because if if there was
if there was
if there was if he did know something
about it he wouldn't be taking a sip of
in a beer
he wouldn't he wouldn't [__] bring
himself
that low to do that
[__] pieces of trash
oh man we got some venmo chants here so
I'll get those up on screen I'm gonna
finish the Ted Cruz video here though
let's see how he let's see how he pivots
to queer beer from ceiling fans
to I kiss my ass beard to Eric bolin's
non-alcoholic beer
to queer beer Bud Light let's listen
which single-handedly seemed to destroy
themselves so I'm glad you're not
drinking a Bud Light personally I'm fond
of Shiner Bock which is a good uh Tech
Texas Brand I've been to the Shiner
Brewery in Shiner Texas and I recommend
it and I promise you this is not
alcohol-free beer down here
he he's an expert on beer because he
went to the Shiner Bock Brewery
in Shiner Texas that makes him an expert
on beer get the [__] out of here
with this nonsense
what a bunch of asshats uh Rico here has
a venmo chat and I'm on
oh boy
says the only they only drink
Dodger draft beer the official beer of
cuck Patriots
but never served that's a good one you
can't serve draft Dodger beer because
it's never served thank you Rico for the
venmo chat if you want to get into the
venmo chat just go to
thetonymichaels.com the Tony
michaels.com the link is at the top of
the page there for a venmo Super Chat
that's right I gotta do a roundabout
thing
we gotta do a roundabout thing because
YouTube hates my guts that's how it goes
we got another one here from Mark
um
now let's see let's see what this one
says now from Mark here
um I gotta I gotta get the see it's a
little bit of a pain in the ass YouTube
for me to do this this is from Mark it
says your takedown of Ted Cruz and his
merry band of [__] Wonders is epic
I've been doing an hour on it
I literally honestly I you know there's
a lot of stories that I could have that
I could have done this morning
and I was like I have this Ted Cruz
thing that'll give me 20 minutes
we're 57 8 or 58 minutes into this thing
and I J I haven't even finished the
[__] clip yet
I haven't finished it yet
just like Ted Cruz is not going to
finish this beer no [__] way is Ted
Cruz gonna finish this beer let's let's
get the last couple seconds here
you know and by the way the one I have
uh right after the show won't be alcohol
free either and it may just be a Vibe
oh the one the one after the show it
definitely won't be one of these one of
these cuck beers that I have these in a
cup beers it'll definitely be a manly
manly manly beer oh it'll be so mad like
it'll make your chest hair grow Ted Cruz
the beer that I'm gonna drink after the
show oh it's gonna make my wenis so big
Jesus Christ these guys this is Newsmax
folks
this is their hard hutting cutting [__]
on Nightly News Max is how what beers
make you more manly than others
Jesus Christ you people on Discord I'm
telling you you guys got to get over to
Discord I say something and there's a
[__] meme or a goddamn gift that just
pops up
they're so goddamn fast and you know
there's like there's lag between when I
say [__] and it goes to the interwebs
and then it pumps back out to you at
YouTube and then it's streaming over on
Discord
oh my God yeah yeah money librarian says
we need help yeah you guys need [__]
Jesus over there for sure I'm not
Christian I'm a I'm an atheist but you
guys need some [__] Jesus over there
get over to the Discord I'm not kidding
you if you like to hang out with a
[__] bam you are not gonna be
disappointed over there I just put the
uh the link in the chat uh that's so
cool
and if you don't have Discord I'm
telling you it's not that difficult it
really isn't it's not that difficult to
figure out Discord and especially get on
the channel in the live show chat
who baby who baby well let's let's do
this let's go to a break everyone think
thank you for the venmo chats today
that's a that's a lot of help to us and
support for the show it really is I know
it seems kind of a roundabout way to get
your chat up on the on the screen but it
helps out the show it helps support the
show because we yeah YouTube doesn't let
me monetize because
I'm a [__] clown I guess I don't know
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after these messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Mega
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the word that I'm struggling with I
chose Babel mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
is that about enough of the Ted screw
[__] I think
now there's some there's some
[Music]
there's some proud girls
sentencing hearing uh was postponed
it was postponed yesterday because the
judge was sick
um they're asking for 33 years and I
believe Biggs
uh was asking for I believe doj the
prosecutors were asking for 33 years but
the guidelines so let me explain this to
you a little bit
because a lot of people don't understand
like the sentencing process and I had to
learn it as well I have ex I have
experience in this everyone thinks I try
to hide my past and stuff they're like
oh my God Tony was in a federal prison
I'm like yeah it's it's my past what do
you want me to do it's something that
happened right
and I'm not going to sit here and
explain exactly why but this is why I
know about federal courts folks
I'm not a lawyer but I know about the
court process because I've been put
through it I know how long it takes I
know how long it stalls I know how easy
it is to stall I know all this stuff and
I know about the sentencing process so
here's the thing with the sentencing
when you go before a sentence sentencing
magistrate okay the magistrate takes a
lot of things in account okay what
they'll do is they'll have a hearing and
you can have witnesses that come and
testify for you right and and like like
in in favor of your character
so let's take let's take Joe Biggs here
the [__] proud boy right
uh judge Kelly is the presiding
magistrate over the sentencing hearing
here and Joe Biggs can have people come
into the court and they can talk to the
judge and testify to the judge of why
Joe Biggs characters should be of such
that the judge shouldn't sentence him to
the rest of his life in prison right in
this case
because doj is asking for 33 years
the prosecutors okay so that's the other
thing is the prosecutors have a chance
to bring in Witnesses
of why why the judgson sentenced him to
what the prosecutors want maybe the
prosecutors want 33 years
then there is the sentencing guidelines
okay these are the federal guidelines
that the pre-trial office puts together
for the judge
there's an officer in the pre-trial
office who goes based on like okay if a
is this then you reach this amount of
the guidelines if you're in if you're a
drug addict or if there's a an uptick in
the terrorism charge which judge Kelly
apparently this morning I was reading
that judge Kelly was going to use uh
terrorism in in their
uh their consideration for this
sentencing because they were tearing
down fences and there were several
different things that evidence and facts
that the judge used to say Yes
um this is an enhanced terrorism charge
now that's what that means enhanced so
enhanced means that you did something
more to get more time on your pre-trial
guidelines
because the guidelines are set in stone
it's the same for each person so
basically what a a pre-trial officer has
to do when they're figuring what the
guidelines for the judge should be
is they're they're just figuring off of
like an algorithm per se and they're
figuring how many months and the the
guidelines which was between 27 and 33
years and they do it by months not years
technically
and when they're doing the guidelines is
how many months you're going to serve
because in in federal prison it's how
many months
and in Most states it's that way too or
days
um months and days
but you can equate it to yours right
but apparently judge Kelly
um going off what the the prosecutors
wanted
um and what the what the guidelines
called for the breaking news here is the
judge Kelly has sentenced proud girl I
mean proud boys excuse me uh Joe Biggs
to 17 years in prison which is a bit
less than Stewart Rhodes the founder of
the oathkeepers now this is an
indication Gabe Sanchez is joining us
Gabe um have you read much about
um this sentencing yet I I read some up
to the point of sentencing but we got to
the show and I had to do an hour on Ted
Cruz pretending he likes beer and I just
had I only I honestly when we were
talking this morning I thought I'm gonna
only get 15 minutes out of it I got I
got a whole hour oh yeah well you know
it doesn't take much to go on Ted Cruz
it is Ted Cruz I can dunk on Ted Cruz
like all day long
um but uh no I I hadn't I hadn't run
this one yet okay so so Joe Biggs he's a
proud boy um he's one of the ones being
sentenced now again yesterday Enrique
atario was scheduled to be sentenced but
uh they had to postpone it because of
Judge Kelly was sick um we were actually
going to run with that story yesterday
um and I thought about running with this
story today but it didn't seem like they
were going to get to the sentencing uh
before we came on air and
I knew I could make time out of Ted Cruz
pretending to like beer I'm just gonna
be quite honest I could make up I mean
the whole the whole interaction it's not
only
it wasn't only
rehearsed on his act right because you
watch it and you're like he's like well
the only thing I have to say is if they
try to force me to drink two beers I
said kiss my ass
first off no one's forcing you to drink
two beers
drink two beers I mean if you don't like
beer you don't have to drink it and if
you like beer you absolutely can drink
it it's legal in this country yeah I
mean there's no one saying that you
can't have beer and there's no one
saying that you can't have more than two
beer and there is one hundred percent
the fact that Joe Biden is not telling
people to do this it's it's like they
thought that uh that Joe Biden
specifically told the National Institute
on alcohol abuse and alcoholism
to say this but they're well they're
listening to this entity that's not hey
now they're the National Association of
alcoholism and ceiling fans because
they're also they're also Banning your
ceiling fans at the same time they're
banning your beer so it's the one and
the same well it's the washing machines
it's the woke stoves
woke Association of of gastos ceiling
fans and beer yeah that's what it is
it's the woke Association yeah I watch
that show I watched that [__] clip
last night and I was like not only do
you have Eric bowling on the show and
he's like oh well and this is how you
know the whole thing was orchestrated
and it was rehearsed so
yeah he goes okay I'll take I'll take my
drink boom kiss my ass [__] dude the
guy can't even defend his own wife from
Donald Trump he's not gonna tell [__] to
him
drinks the beer and everyone else oh
that's our cue okay uh drink the beer
and then Eric bolling's like well I'm on
air so I can't drink alcoholic so I'll
have this he they what a [__] what a
[__] [__] Eric Bo Eric Eric hey Eric
I'm dead serious man come on the show uh
I'll act like I've yeah I'll actually
let you drink beer on my show you
[__] cuck you're scared of your
contract where it says you can't drink
alcohol on air and he tore the label off
the beer too what a [__] [__] Eric
Boone you can't even give the
non-alcoholic beer the crazy you can't
give them that free advertising right
it's really what he's doing was he
probably pulled the label off a Bud
Light
that's what that's probably what it was
uh let's get back to this uh Joe Biggs
thing 17 years in prison the doj because
I was just telling the audience that the
how they sentence people to prison is
that there's three different kind of
suggestions here there's the there's the
actual suggestion um
from the doj based on the guidelines and
that's kind of like black and white
right it's a pre-trial officer who puts
together the guidelines based on the
case and the sentencing and all that
kind of stuff and they're like they
present this to the judges hey judge
based on the federal guidelines the the
federal the the federal black and white
thing it's it looks like he should be
sentenced between 27 and 33 years and
then the prosecutors give their
recommended which the prosecutors in
this case has went all the way up to 33
years they obviously Joe uh Joe Biggs
gave no cooperation whatsoever because
the prosecutor is like oh the guy lines
are 33 years give that [__] 33
years and then you have the actual
sentencing from the judge which is 17
years in this case so that's where those
three numbers come in they want the
audience to understand that because
um we're gonna have this stupid [__]
where all these these [__] trumpers
um
there's a lot of trumpers have been
sentenced already for the Insurrection
but I'm talking about the people uh in
the state elector scheme and
um in the DC scheme where we where we
see Jack's been Prosecuting Donald Trump
and possibly uh charging and indicting
some of these co-conspirators through a
grand jury so we're going to see a lot
of this stuff uh for the sentencing but
that's how it works in the federal
system the state system each State's a
little different
um so that's where the 17 years comes in
I actually believe that the judge went
white on Joe Biggs here yeah I mean
we're looking at something that is
almost half of the max sentence that's
there I mean obviously enriquechario got
the whole
the whole nine yards on that one
but wait they sentenced Enrique tario I
thought it was 30. no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no they resched that's
what they recommended because Enrique
Charlie and Joe Biggs because they have
about the same kind of criminal
background their guidelines are about
the same well not only the same amount
of criminal background but they're also
of leadership positions of The Proud
boys so that's that's what um yeah sorry
I misspoke
um
I wouldn't be surprised if tario gets
also for the fact that you know he
wasn't supposed to be in DC like
literally told get the [__] out of DC
and then he stayed in DC for you know
planning and then he left because he
wasn't there for January 6th
well speaking of January 6 here is um if
you can you'll see Joe Biggs in this
video
um and just just get a sense of why he
got 17 years here
foreign
[Applause]
[__] around find out I mean if you go
you go all the way back
and you say hey guys uh this chant is
really gonna bite you in the ass like
this chant is going to be your anthem as
you get sentenced to prison
well I want to also point out um Joe
Biggs here speaking of like Texas
politicians now this is a little blurry
picture who's connected this is Joe
Biggs here right and he has a and this
is hilarious he has a Benghazi shirt of
course but who is he shaking hands with
who is this who is this uh fascist
looking gentleman here that he's shaking
hands with he's a Public Enemy Number
One against trees oh okay I get you okay
I got you and then also is there
something I just wanna I gotta go I
gotta ask this question do trees not
like Republican governors
well I mean you're talking about a tree
that fell on Rhonda Santos's house too
yeah like I just wonder are are trees
coming after Republican Governors
I mean they could be I mean maybe it's
retaliation you know you [__] around you
find out I mean that's what we know
right
um here's another here's another video
um of Joe Biggs who just received 17
years to try to overturn them
so we just stormed the [__]
thank you
[Music]
so much America so much wow
yes it is yes videos
we just stormed the capital we took it
over man yeah [__] we stormed the
capital we took it back oh man that was
so great what a crazy day uh this day
will live in infamy
it will again
the rakes keep hitting one after another
and no one has the foresight to say hey
we just we just broke into a federal
building right that that's a felony like
we did we smeared [__] on the wall we
tore [__] down we stole laptops stole
envelopes that's a felony right there so
this is conspiracy look at them they're
smiling and they're because because why
because they thought that in some weird
alternate timeline Universe they were
gonna get away with what they did and
even if they weren't successful in
getting Trump to still stay remain as
president they're like yeah yeah but
we're [__] Patriots and we ran by the
Constitution and we [__] showed them
who's boss so the next time they try to
steal an election they'll think twice
yeah well I hope you have those thoughts
in the next 17 years you're in prison
[__] well here's here's the thing also
he's gonna be a complete [__] when he
gets it oh [__] yeah someone's gonna be
like hold on to my pocket [__]
you're mine now
so
this is the same this this attitude in
this video right this is the same
attitude that cheese burrow and Sydney
Powell still have in Georgia they're
like oh yeah because the reason why
they're on film like yeah we stormed the
capital we we committed so many federal
felonies just now it's awesome because
we're gonna get away with it because
Donald Trump's gonna be the king and
he's going to save us yeah that's what
Pitney Sydney pound cheese Bro think
it's the same [__] like yeah we'll go
yeah
trial
trial no it's legal like that's
literally what their attitude is and
funny was like all right bet yeah let's
go [__] around you want it you want to
go tomorrow if you want I have
everything ready I hope you're ready
because clearly you're so confident that
you're innocent that there's no reason
that you need any more preparation than
you already have especially because you
just requested that we accelerate and
move the timetable up for the uh for the
court or the the the court hearing so
hey let's do it
none of these people think none of these
people think they never think things
forward they never future proof things
we've seen it again and again Joe Biden
stickers I did that yeah well the price
went down Joe Biden inflation price went
down Joe Biden job numbers they went up
you've got this moment right now where
they're bragging again these are the
people that showed up with ID badges and
posted to their own personal profiles on
Twitter parlor Facebook all of these
places and then we're like oh my God why
are we being charged with something
because you admitted to committing a
crime you [__] idiot and you showed
your face and you entered a building
where your cell phone is a literal
tracking device and that's how they knew
how to find you none of these people
ever I mean like I swear that the
remaining two brain cells in a maga's
head that are like barely rubbing
together to like spark a [__] thought
they do not have the foresight to think
ahead and say oh should I do this are
there going to be consequences if I [__]
around right now will I find out Well
turns out you are you're all [__]
finding out real hard right now
uh you know the the thing that got me
about
um some of the back and forth in the
sentencing hearing and I'm trying to
find the uh the quote here
but it makes me think that Alex Jones is
a Fed
you know they say this all the time like
oh these Nazis showing up they're all
feds they're all feds I don't I don't
know if you know this
um and we talked about this on the show
before and we've talked about with uh
Dakota Adams Stuart Rhodes the founder
of the oath keeper son and his wife
and his ex-wife Tasha Adams uh that's
Stuart Rhodes his ex-wife Tash Adams we
talked about how
um Stuart Rhodes would be on Alex
Jones's Infowars right his show but not
only that that Alex Jones would have
Stuart sleep on his couch when Stewart
was kind of like Couchsurfing where he
didn't have a place to live
um apparently Biggs
Joe Biggs actually worked for Alex Jones
um which I think is significant but in
in the sentencing hearing and I'm trying
to find it here there's just so much um
about the sentencing here Alex Jones
comes up in the sentencing hearing and
Alex Jones has not been charged with
anything with anything he was at the
Capitol he was he was communicating with
proud boys and Oath Keepers they were
trying uh we know cheese burrow the guy
charged in Georgia as one of the
architects of the of this fake State
electricity in Georgia and all around
it's just all around architect with uh
John Eastman we know that he was with
Alex Jones during the Insurrection so
it's like an inside guy with Alex Jones
man it almost feels like it almost feels
like to me and you know I'm just I'm
just putting this out there this maybe
is my 10-ball hat talking almost feels
like to me Alex Jones is a fed I'm just
gonna say that I think Alex to me it
feels like Alex Jones comes up in all
these proud boy cases
um the cheese again cheese bro is with
Alex Jones it feels like
it feels like when they accuse neo-nazis
of being feds they're looking for the
wrong one it's the guy they're listening
to
it's the guy they're listening to on
Infowars that's the thing yeah I don't
uh I don't know I'm I've never heard
that before
well I'm gonna have a hard time looking
for this because anytime I search in
Alex Jones fed it's going to be the
complete opposite of him
uh accusing someone else of being the
FED right well you know projection is a
line of their game
and Alex Jones Alex Jones to me again
when you look at this case of January 6
because again Alex Jones has not
received any repercussions you know
who's another guy that's never received
any kind of repercussions against us so
far Ali Alexander Ali Alexander is a
really good friend of Alex Jones it
almost feels like to me and you know the
crazy part about Ollie Alexander is
they're in a big huge Feud with Marjorie
Taylor green
I'm very much waiting for this uh this
info to be revealed
from uh Ali Alexander yes the idea that
he's like I got [__] on Margie Taylor
green oh yeah he's like this rage this
rage he's done it a couple times what's
the platform telegram is that where you
did this then no no it wasn't on
telegram it was another it was a um
uh cozy TV I think somebody was
basically it was like it was cozy TV
which is associated with Nick Fuentes
cozy TV somebody had a show or has a
show and they had him on and he said
I've Got dirt on Margie Taylor green the
state of Georgia would like to know what
this info is because she lied she lied
under oath during that trial which by
the way Margaret Taylor green
who was in court last year
she goes uh uh she had a tweet yesterday
I think Tweeter two days ago and she
said um we should have cameras in the
courtroom for Trump why don't we have
cameras in the courtroom for these
Federal cases and then I was like you
[__] dumbass there's a reason why
because she was like well there was a
there was a camera in my court case
because it was a state level [__] you
know what she's such a dumb [__] man I'm
just I can't
I can't it's hard anyway it's hard to
it's hard when you get supposedly yeah I
know supposedly uh Ollie Alexander has
aka the doppelganger for Sammy Davis Jr
has
um dirt on Margaret Taylor green now I'm
not sure if he actually does or when he
plans to release it but I wouldn't be
surprised considering the fact of how
incestuous all of their relationships
were at one point
the fact that Nick Fuentes was revealing
some of Marjorie Taylor green and then
when Marjorie Taylor green hit at uh
Laura Loomer and also Nick Fuentes that
Ali Alexander was like okay you know
what I got dirt on this woman and the
state of Georgia would like to know
because she committed I think he said
she committed perjury and there was
other stuff that she had done right well
I mean there's a lot of accusations out
there between that Feud of Laura Loomer
margin and it's all directed at Marjorie
Taylor green
um which hey you know what I told Laura
Loomer last week I even tagged her in it
I think I'm like hey keep going
oh no that was more than that was more
than a week ago that was I was I went to
go see a movie that was like maybe three
weeks ago no no no last week when Laura
Loomer showed up and she was shouting at
Marjorie right right I thought you were
talking about this latest time
with the one where you you retweeted you
quote tweeted and then she followed you
oh yeah she yeah Laura Loomer follows I
think she still follows me yeah yeah I I
forget what it was I
said something and I [__] I I said I
quote Tweeter and she followed me I'm
like and I said make it stop stop make
it stop it was something she said was
like I was like I agree with it it made
sense I agree why am I agreeing with
Laura Loomer and she follows me I'm like
please make it stop do not don't do this
to me but here's I finally found um Kyle
Cheney was reporting this on his Twitter
um and this was in the courtroom Biggs
also indicated in some video played by
prosecutors that he was trying to get in
touch with Alex Jones and had some
intention to meet up with him as the
group marched towards the capital now
think about this for a second okay think
about this Biggs is the guy who just got
sentenced he's been convicted of
seditious conspiracy he's just been
sentenced to Smart this morning today
um it's this morning here today you know
this afternoon where it was at
but Joe Baker sentenced the 17 years for
seditious conspiracy now
Alex Jones is on the grounds the capital
with Donald one of Donald Trump's
attorneys who is the architect of this
the fake State elector scheme standing
next to Alex Jones we have video of it
we have
[__] pictures of cheeseburger walking
around with Alex Jones
why the [__] does Joe Biggs need to get
in touch with Alex Jones
because we know Stuart Rhodes was
looking for a liaison to Trump's ear
which it just so happens Roger Stone
knows Donald Trump's [__] cell phone
number
communicates with him on that cell phone
and there was an oath keeper standing
next to Roger Stone almost the entire
day Ryder Stone there's actually a video
of Roger Stone from that documentary
he's really pissed off he wasn't used in
the Insurrection because he's like at
one point it's like we got to get out of
here because he knows that there's
trouble yeah right but Roger Stone at
first he's kind of pissed off that that
they didn't use him more for the
Insurrection and and I don't know maybe
and you know you know what else is funny
about that Roger Stone is on Infowars
and Alex Jones Show all the time it's
almost like it's almost like all these
people are part of the same conspiracy
gave zinjes and it feels like the reason
why Alex Jones
and maybe stage your own as we know him
on the show yes Dodger Rhone the
infamous dodgerone right it maybe it
feels like maybe there's a couple feds
in this group uh circle jerk that's
going on with these uh can we call it a
conspiracy circle jerk can we call it
that is that true is that okay for me to
call him then do you think you could
okay the conspiracy circle jerk but it
seems like there's a few guys standing
in the circle jerk that are 100 feds and
it seems like it's probably Alex Jones
and stodgerone because they seem to be
the only ones that haven't gotten any
consequence it's almost like they they
were the feds on the ground because you
know Republicans are like we want to
know how many fans we're all good
wouldn't that be quite the reveal going
from from Tucker Carlson going on this
conspiracy now here's the thing cucker
Carlson will be like I was right I told
you all there were feds there
oh my God I'm not I'm not saying there
was feds on the ground and I'm not
saying I know for sure that stodger Roan
uh AKA Roger Stone and Alex Jones are
feds but it really seems like they're
they're gay frog fans who sniffed too
many Chemtrails with the demons I'm just
saying I'm just saying it's very much a
possibility I think who knows I think
people are saying that now people are
sad people in the chat are now saying
that there's a big many people are many
people are saying it but there's a it is
a very big question that you have to ask
yourself which is like how is Roger
Stone not in any of these
indictments wasn't Alex Jones one of his
little co-hosts or something one of his
little cut co-hosts it wasn't in charge
wouldn't he charged or something what
was that guy's name who which one uh the
guy on him
his name he's a cook he's he's one of
these Alpha cup types they think they're
[__] cool they think they're manly he
probably pretends to drink shinerbach
beer as well
um
yeah that's right wasn't he charged he
wasn't charged in a January 6th Capital
riots yes he hosted the program in the
right wing blah blah blah always been
charging connection with January 6th
right of the US capital according the
war room with no insurance for the
website operated by Alex Jones there's a
lot of questions since I have answers
okay misdemeanor charges such as
disorderly conduct and entering a
restricted area to Capital grounds
he got misdemeanor not felonies he got
he faces misdemeanor charges such as
disorderly conduct and entering a
restricted area of capital grounds
so misdemeanors yep hmm
it's almost like what's his name Eli
what no his name is um
Owen Owen Shroyer Owen shoyer Owen Owen
hey man it almost feels like
you do buddy
misdemeanors really man misdemeanors did
your did your did your boss and co-host
did he help did he help get you a deal
and that's not the only one hold on
Shroyer is the second person who works
for Infowars to face federal charges
stepping from January 6. Samuel Montoya
and Infowars video editor was arrested
in April in charges including impeding
passage to the Capitol grounds when Toya
spoke to an infowar show about
witnessing a capital officer shooting
kill woman AKA [__] Ashley Babbitt uh
this was but this mind you this is
August 20th 2021 so they were one of the
first ones out of the batch that were
charged for these crimes I don't know if
uh and it's misdemeanors did he did is
it a felony that they charged the the
was the cameraman you're saying uh
cameraman yeah okay so as of June 23rd
um it says Owen shroy was promoted
basically who promoted basic claims of
the 2020 election fraud pleaded guilty
on Friday to joining a mob of Donald
Trump supporters who ride at the U.S
Capitol
Shroyer who didn't enter the building
but led rioters in chance to near the
top of the building steps pleaded guilty
to a misdemeanor charge of illegally
entering a restricted area the charge
carries a maximum sentence of one year
Behind Bars
uh scheduled a September 12th hearing so
it hasn't happened yet so he's got
September 12th sense in hearing so
that's coming up the next 12 days
uh for his charges I wonder I wonder if
he'll just get probation for his role
we'll just get probation for his role in
uh I wonder who the judges judge Timothy
Kelly let's see if he's done anyone else
uh Kelly is the one he just sentenced
Joe Biggs oh well there you go so maybe
he does give him the Max on this I'm not
sure or well I mean I mean uh to be
honest uh judge kelly didn't come
anywhere near the guidelines I mean the
guys for 27 to 33 years he lowered it
down to 17. he didn't even give him a
dirty 30. dirty 30 in the federal system
is 20 plus 10 on probation yeah so who
knows maybe he gives him a quarter of
the time like a few months in prison or
or just all a creation probation I don't
know but yeah that's that's a maximum
sense of one year behind bars I don't
know what that translates to probation
yeah well and the other thing too is uh
what the guidelines will be for
um the video video guy and Owen but you
said it's the video guy who has the uh
the
the hearing on the 12th
no no no that's Shroyer okay okay now if
I look up Montoya yeah see what see if
he's got a hearing coming up soon I
don't know I just you know it feels like
to me
every time we do this stupid thing where
the Patriot front because they think
they're all feds yeah which if you go
watch their training videos they're
definitely not feds he gets he got three
years of probation see there you go he's
the he's the Infowars employee who
filmed the January 6th shooting is sent
to home detention
uh who worked for a conspiracy theory
Alex Jones was sentenced on Wednesday to
four months of home detention for
joining a mobs attack
um employed a video editor who filmed I
don't know it seems Seems like honestly
if you're adjacent to Joe Biggs and
Stuart Rhodes who receives 17 20 years I
mean these people are you know
prosecuted this is a different judge
though this one was Judge John Bates
which I don't know what his see that the
judges the J you know what the other
thing about sentencing is that the
judges see is the judges see all the on
are the unsealed documents and sealed
documents right so the judge sees
everything that's behind that's behind
the prosecutors and and that that
protective of a seal because when you do
a deal there's an unsealed deal and a
sealed deal and the judge sees both of
them so it says here prosecutors
recommended sentencing Montoya to 45
days of imprisonment
Bates instead sends Montoya to three
years of probation including four months
of home detention and 60 hours of
community service in order him to pay a
fifteen hundred dollar fine plus 500 in
restitution the judge said it was a
close call quote unquote in deciding to
spare him from incarceration
okay are you catching on here do you see
the pattern that I'm talking about well
it's quite awesome I mean I'm not saying
they are but there is way more
possibility that Alex Jones and his
editor and his co-host are his
videographer his video guy his cameraman
and his co-host are feds more than
Patriot front there's way more evidence
to suggest that and I'm just saying that
and you shouldn't you shouldn't take my
word for it but you should definitely go
maybe ask other people on the internet
if that's the case I'm telling the
audience you should go ask other people
on the internet they think Alex Jones a
friend is he a vet is Alex Jones a fed
and has he been a Fed for a long time it
almost maybe even maybe even he was a
Fed on the ground that's what Tucker
Carlson you know you make a good point
yeah maybe that's what Tucker Carlson's
maybe that maybe he was right maybe he
was just he just wasn't right about the
person right you know thinking that this
was going to be some democrat some FBI
agent somewhere in the in the Biden
Administration even though riling up the
crowd to go take over like maybe maybe a
libtard yeah like Joe Biggs doesn't that
you know what I find I find that
argument funny when they're like it was
a Fed who coerced these people into
doing this
so you're telling me that there were
feds on the ground
that have the ability to manipulate
a swath of people at one time to force
them into the building who are
definitely not Sheep by the way they're
not cheap and they definitely won't do
the same thing that they're told to do
and then right exactly the same they
won't change the same thing yes they
don't live the same life they would
never do that they don't get grifted to
the same guy right you're telling me
that FBI agents planted in the sea of
people that were there on January 6th
somehow had some Mentalist ability to
just say everyone
Riot everyone stormed the capital and
then you had Joe yeah Joe Biggs who was
like oh man we just stormed the [__]
capital and there's an FBI agent that's
back he's like good keep saying that
right right
that doesn't make any sense what no well
you know what else doesn't make sense
John Eastman went on uh Barbie Nazi's
show on Fox news last night our Nazi
Barbie is it Nazi Barbie or Barbie Nazi
Nazi Barbie is what it is it's Nazi
Barbie because it has to be like oh look
it's Christmas Barbie it's the whatever
the descriptor is before yeah yeah Nazi
Barbie John Eastman
speaking of saying really stupid [__] on
camera oh my god did he do this multiple
times he I don't he'll keep doing it
there I mean again like he literally is
admitting to the crime that he's charged
with right here on camera like he's
admitting to it like what the [__] are
you shut he's supposed to be an attorney
like Mo almost every attorney would know
it the only time you go on a given
interview is with your other attorney
who's representing you in the case to
tell you to shut up no Tony but he's an
attorney though so why would he need an
attorney though he's like if I'm an
attorney why do I need an attorney right
exactly well you know again they're like
dude you're you you might not be an
attorney much longer he's is he an
attorney is is he I think I think or did
they strip him is he suspended I don't
think he's been disbarred yet oh okay
well this is the same I think I think
the thing he was trying to argue is he
wanted to put off the trial or he wanted
to put off the disparment hearing
because he was being because they were
happening at the same time yeah the
judge is like no I don't give a [__]
it's not my fault that right you
committed these crimes look what do you
want me to do either way it doesn't look
good whether you push one or the other
you're still being investigated for
these crimes and you're still under our
investigation oh my God but here in the
same style that that Joe Biggs is
standing outside the camp like yeah we
stormed the capital we committed so many
felonies and I'm probably gonna go to
prison for 17 years for it here's John
Eastman doing the same [__] thing on
Nazi Barbie show last night watch this
this is crazy John and just again so as
we clarify this on January 6th yeah what
did you want to happen okay and how was
that historically
grounded and the history of our country
how would that have taken place so just
so the viewers can understand what would
have unfolded and how that would have
ultimately been constitutional it she
could have been really simple here of
course she's got to do a roundabout
thing she could have just been so what
can you tell us what crimes you wanted
to commit on January 6. could you tell
us the crimes that you wanted to commit
and how you wanted can you just go
through the game time right like this
what was the meeting like at the hotel
what was the PowerPoint presentation
what was the actual uh legal like uh
arguments that you were thinking not
non-legal and then also what were the
actual steps you took knowing that what
you were doing was illegal right and we
definitely are not recording this and
this is definitely not live here
National TV right now and you're not
being interviewed
Okay let's listen for sure though I am
sure his his lawyer is like ah God damn
it [__] bro oh yeah oh you know well I
mean if he can get a decent lawyer but
let's let's watch John Eastman describe
his crimes here
so there you know several things some
people at urged that vice president
Pence simply had power to reject con
electors uh whose certification was
still pending okay so he's like several
things oh there's several crimes so to
take a seat and several there's several
crimes they're going to talk about here
let me just go through each one right A
to Z right right let's zero the crime
how much time do you have because how
much time do you have it might take me a
while to describe this conspiracy that
we came up with this one's gonna take a
minute I hope you uh I hope you have a
drink put your take your shoes out put
your feet up do you have an in a beer do
you have an in a beer available like
already open with the label off of it
that you could drink uh as a prop let's
let's keep listening Jesus Christ these
people yeah I don't believe that but go
ahead I don't believe that I I don't
know that's one thing I don't agree with
and I that's she's so full of [__]
[__] I guarantee if we go back to late
December early January of 2020 2021
Warren is on Fox News like bike pants he
better he better certify Donald Trump he
better be sure where do you think these
people got this idea you [__]
boneheads they got it from Nazi Barbie
and her ilk that's where it was a
complete if you watch the the the the I
guess we can call it a dialogue but if
you watch the conversations that were
happening
and you saw it during the White House as
well Trump would watch Fox News he would
get the talking points and he'd
regurgitate those talking points on air
at a press conference and then those
would just keep it was like a game of
telephone he'd hear one thing and maybe
he repeats something similar and then it
would get regurgitated into the media
and then they would keep playing around
this is the same thing a lot of these
people including Fox News on Newsmax had
lawyers on their shows to talk about
what was legal and what wasn't legal
they talk about the constitutionality of
what was happening at the election and
then happening and then saying what
Trump could do and what couldn't do and
hearing the talking points from these
people you had Donald Trump listening
and saying whoa wait this guy just said
that I could do this on Fox News and
somebody might say well yeah not really
or they might say well that's an
interesting Theory it's [__] batshit
but we'll try it and it was just this
non-stop constant cycle of them going
back and forth and back and forth of him
hearing one thing repeating it them
saying well Trump said it so now it's a
real thing and then having people Double
Down triple down quadruple down to the
fact where they ended up committing
these crimes because they thought they
could
exactly well listen it because John
Eastman backs off the whole Trump or the
Pence thing here that he can Crown Trump
King but listen to what he says after it
it's hilarious how he's like no what
they didn't do what they what they're
saying we did we did exactly what
they're saying we did
and I explicitly told vice president
pence in the Oval Office on January 4th
that even though it was an open issue
under the circumstances we had I thought
it was the weaker argument and it would
be foolish to exercise such power even
if he had it
so he he literally said he's literally
saying yes I agreed I didn't want them
to do that but that is what I that was
like a last ditch effort type thing that
was that was the hail Mary did he
he didn't he's saying no I didn't want
it but I told Pence that even if he had
the power which he he doesn't maybe I
mean possibly he probably does have it I
mean I want him to have it and the
reason why I want him to have it is
because I wanted Trump to be king this
was some weird way for him to be like
look yes people did talk about this
stuff but I was clearly saying don't do
it but at the same time I was saying if
you wanted to right right right right
right I'm gonna look look if I turn my
back right now right and this happens to
go missing off the table
I didn't see it right and he and he
points out a meeting to the Oval Office
which is even worse for his legal case
here that he's out in public talking
about specific meetings that they can
pinpoint when the meeting was and now
they can go back and look at Witnesses
and go wait a second wait a second what
a [__] bonehead no real lawyer would
get on TV and talk about a pinpointed
specific [__] meeting and exactly
what you said in that meeting I think I
think you just you just nailed it no
real lawyer well that is true again we
say over and over on this show that it
can't be that hard to be an attorney I
apologize to all attorneys especially
the good ones out there there are smart
attorneys out there there are people who
they work hard job and they work hard
and they are talented but then somehow
there are other people who slip through
the cracks
it's just pretty much every lawyer that
Trump has ever been Associated maybe
it's just some State bars are not hard
to get on the stage yeah I don't know
well let's let's continue with how he's
going to describe the crime here what I
recommended and I've said this here we
go is that he exceeds a requests from
more than a hundred state legislators in
the swing states to give them a week to
try and sort out the impact of what
everybody acknowledged was illegality in
the conduct of the election election
okay Mike Pence not only is it
bone-headed to think that he has the
power to Crown a king it's also
boneheaded to think that Mike Pence
could just say you know what [__] you
you're going to take another week that
is not he did not have that power he
Mike Pence did not have the power to say
[__] your state electors go get new ones
that he doesn't have the power to say he
all's Mike Pence was he held the gavel
to throw the gavel down to open a
meeting he has to follow he has to
follow the meetings rules and they have
to present the State Certified electors
and then they have to acknowledge not
vote on they have to acknowledge those
State electors existence that is his
only [__] job is to put the
acknowledgment of those State electors
in the federal Congressional Record that
is it period there is no changing it
there's no I don't like it so send it
back none of that [__] exists in Mike
Pence's realm or any vice president's
realm that's all [__] and let's
remember that this certification has
happened after states have gone back
multiple states have gone back to do
recounts right which was Georgia who was
like look man three times three [__]
times constant taxpayers money and each
time what happened each and here here's
what I find funny each time they
recounted like in Arizona and Georgia
they ended up finding that there were
more votes for Joe Biden right every
time they're like no no it's going to
happen this time we're going to find
more we're going to find now 12 000
votes we're going to find the 15 000
votes that we need and it turns out that
every time they recounted they're like
oh actually this is a a vote for like
here might be one more for uh Donald
Trump well here is actually a handful
for Joe Biden
because now you've got people who are
going through and doing an audit again
on the taxpayer dime
just like just like Donald Trump doing
his Caravan coming in to surrender
himself
on uh in Fulton County last week
but when you when you look at this you
have to remember because John Eastman is
going to come up with something like oh
you know Mike Pence had the ability to
send it back and say it's not worthy and
then what really is the fact is these
states had multiple recounts they said
they're like well look it's not going to
change the outcome if anything is going
to show that Joe Biden won by even more
votes so what we're going to do now is
we've done it multiple times we're
sending it off and we're going to send
it to the capitals to be certified and
Johnny says like oh no no no Mike Pence
can most certainly reject it if he wants
to it's like no that that we leave it in
a world of Truth
and lie and we live in a world of
science and non-fiction and the
Republican Party lives in this weird
[__] alternative universe that's
non-fiction or sorry it is fiction and
and and and lies and that's what they
have and they don't have anything to run
I I don't know what Donald I don't know
if Donald's
um talking to us here specifically or
what he's talking about
um and I think I think he might be
talking about I think he might be
responding to
and I'm not really sure so Donald I like
for you to clarify this statement but if
Donald is saying everyone did not agree
like they didn't agree that the states
um that the election was won by Joe
Biden and all the recounts were
legitimate they were legitimate recounts
they were done by election officials
this is the thing that that's been done
uh man you're it and again I don't know
if and what Donald's talking about here
but it's in all camps
so I wanted to clarify it but here's the
thing I'm assuming that he's he's
talking to John Eastman but if the
sentiment here is because this is the
sentiment of a lot of manga they're like
but we feel like it feels like to us
because we didn't want Joe Biden to win
so it feels like Donald Trump won so
because we feel this way then we get our
way and that's just not how it works and
that's what John Eastman is literally
saying in this clip is that we didn't
like the results so we get to do
something that doesn't exist in the
Constitution because we didn't like the
results and we get to make up this whole
week thing that's all [__] made up
it's all made up it's actually part of
the state elector scheme of why he's
indicted in Georgia the craziest part is
Ted Cruz went to the floor of the Senate
during during this whole [__]
Shenanigans of this state electors thing
because Ted Cruz was directed because
let's face it Donald Trump has something
on Ted Cruz that's just [__] fact of
the matter because Ted Cruz went to the
floor and described this weak thing that
doesn't exist it's not a thing Mike
Pence tried really hard he did he tried
so hard Gabe Sanchez to figure out a way
to subvert the democracy and and to to
get rid of the Constitution and throw
this to Donald Trump he really tried
that really hard he even went even went
to a former vice president to see if it
was I mean he couldn't spell potato
uh but he went to a former vice
president to see if that was a thing
that he could just Crown Donald Trump
King but he found out in his search for
any reason to make uh to appease Donald
Trump that he would actually go to a
federal prison is what he would do yeah
Mike Pence would go to a federal prison
if he would do what John Eastman and
Donald Trump was asking to rather he was
rather they were asking him to accept
the fake electors or do the weak thing
he would go to federal prison because he
was knownly committing felonies but
let's listen to the known felonies that
John Eastman is admitting to right here
on camera
yeah not everyone acknowledged it but
that was the argument that was being
made obviously and they were obviously
irregularities that everybody had seen
but whether that was yeah whether it
Rose to the level of changing the
outcome of the election again without a
legal proceeding in the states that
mattered the the argument ultimately was
a difficult one to make I mean hence
hence here we are even Nazi Barbie even
even Nazi Barbie is sitting here going
dude you just admitted to the crime
they're convicting you of and and let's
not forget
that Fox News has to be very careful
about how they position their talking
points now they can't just openly accept
some conspiracy I mean if John Eastman
wants to admit to these crimes on air
that's all on him they're not the ones
that are pushing it they're just asking
questions and talking to them and he's
the one revealing it but Laura Ingraham
has clearly learned from the example
that's been set by Tucker Carlson and
others where you cannot push this
conspiracy especially one that has been
fact-checked and debunked again and
again and again which is Mike Pence did
not have the authority to overturn the
electors and send them back to the state
level or assign new electors because he
didn't like what the results were he was
like look man this is what it is I got a
vote on this and then let's certify it
because I do not have the ability to do
anything other than this and Laura
Ingraham understands that she can't go
out there and face these conspiracies
anymore because they are already held
liable to 787.5 million dollars from
Dominion in they've got a 1.3 billion
dollar lawsuit from smartmatic and
there's other there's other
investigations that are happening but
they know wholeheartedly that they
cannot spread this that's why Ducey on
Fox and Friends will continuously be
like do you have the evidence so what
you're saying is this but they never go
off and claim it to be truth speaking of
that oh here's a great moment of about
evidence and who has evidence and who
doesn't on Hannity last night of Jim
Comer watch this this is this is so
[__] funny and we believe now you
have evidence that Joe Biden benefited
financially himself although that's not
easy oh my God wait wait game Sanchez
they're going to show the evidence right
here on this clip just hang on hang on a
minute hang on a minute they're going to
show the evidence they have it they have
it let's let's see it Jim Comer's gonna
show it right here on screen let's do it
correct
I think so yes wow
can they just go on the air and say they
have the evidence they have 100 because
every time they go there he says uh I
think so I hope so we're looking into it
looks like it to me I want it to be a I
want to find the evidence
just I mean come on guys if you're gonna
go in and commit to this at least at
least lie about it and say you have the
[__] evidence right right at least
lie like grandpa will oh my God these
[__] rants from him oh I've got I
wrote a dude I stayed up late last night
writing a what was that for this thing
because I was I was like oh I was
writing a Vivek one and then I saw these
clips you're like nope got a pivot I was
like this dude went on a [__] Bender
it's like the it's like the friends meme
pivot pivot
when they're carrying the count of the
people are friends fans you'll know what
I'm talking about here is um here's
Grandpa this is [__] real folks which
one is this one well I'm not really sure
because there were so many there are 30
if people don't know this I watched
every single video there are 31 videos
in total and I watch them for you so you
don't have to
I'm going to show you one right here
it's only 31. my eye Tony my eyes were
bleeding right after I washed it right
um well your eyes might bleed after this
one too now the reason why I repost this
because when I first saw this I'm like
is this [__] real like is this is
this because I mean we got a lot of good
AI is getting better and better every
day yeah I guess getting better and
better every day so I was like this
could be fake this could be a fake but
this is [__] real he really said this
[__] they really recorded it and then
they posted it on the Internet it's
[__] real listen to this it's crazy
[__] how dare low-life prosecutor
deranged Jack Smith that's right he's
deranged break into my former Twitter
account without informing me and indeed
trying to completely hide this atrocity
from me what could he possibly find out
that is not already known just like the
early morning raid of Mar-A-Lago why
isn't the doj rating crooked Joe Biden's
house
why aren't they rating his phones he's
the most corrupted and competent
president in the history of the United
States so you're a low life prosecutor
deranged so in other words so in other
words they're going to keep rating
Trump's house and they got his phone
yeah he's saying he's telling you folks
they got his phone yeah his phone they
took my phone
they came in early morning while I was
having my Metamucil orange just like the
color of my skin that's how I get my
wonderful complexion but they came in
August day 2022 raining through my house
going through melania's pennies
they didn't let me smell them
[Music]
oh my God he is he is so confused about
how a warrant works like he is so
confused because he's like broke into my
Twitter account what the [__] are you
talking about they didn't like hack your
Twitter account they went to Twitter and
said hey [__] we got a warrant for his
[__] his day you know who fought on
his behalf yeah and lost and had to pay
what was almost 400 Grand yeah because
they wouldn't comply with the warrant
yeah I'm not a [__] idiot like they
just died
I mean also a company that is so
strapped for cash right now and trying
to find new ways to generate Revenue was
like you know what
We're Not Gonna We're not gonna do this
we are not oh we're gonna get sanctioned
for this okay [__] uh all right uh so we
just lost 350 to 400 000 and what we
would have had for budgetary reasons uh
looks like a couple more people gotta go
Judo Chuck
here's the thing here's another job
Cheeto chap here's the thing about the
um this
this tells me a couple different things
number one there's a ton of
incriminating [__] on Twitter I told you
I told you he's got [__] on there a time
he had conversation with Mark Meadows he
was dming people on that [__]
about all this and just like I told you
he downloaded the messages thinking
thinking that would erase them this is
where he says the select committee
deleted everything because he deleted
everything off Twitter he downloaded he
was like I deleted the messages it's
only one way and it's like no that just
because you delete a message on your end
doesn't actually delete it in entirety
so what ended up happening was he
downloaded thinking it was deleted then
he shredded it then he ate it then he
shout it out and then he was like I
gotta flush the toilet 10 to 15 times
you gotta flash those toilets 10 times
to get rid of the evidence you gotta
flush them 10 times 10 times you smell
that you smell that
spider down the toilet yep he's not
coming back that's a big [__] oh my God
but but the second thing that tells you
because when he says at the end why
didn't they take Joe Biden's phone they
got his phone [__] yeah and I'm
not just talking about the physical
phone they got all the data all the data
from his [__] phone that's what he's
pissed off about because he's like why
why are they taking Joe Biden they took
my phone why didn't they take his phone
because he didn't commit crime on it you
dumb bastard and not only that but he
also gave it up he gave everything he
was like yeah if you if the FBI wants to
come search my second home they want to
come through the garage my office this
and that totally fine totally yes it oh
no it's not it's not on Rumble Rob Law
asks is it on Rumble it's not on Rumble
where is it at
so these videos that he posts are not 31
of them 31 videos 31 videos should we go
watch it I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding the audience is like Jesus
[__] Christ Jesus Christ look I'll
give you a little sample in one video he
calls Rupert Murdoch a globalist in
another video he goes after Joe Biden
taking vacations which funny uh but on
top of that he goes Joe Biden shirtless
on a beach doesn't look good he
shouldn't be without a shirt on
so he's contemplating Joe Biden's nudity
yeah well he's doing the same thing that
everyone else is like oh look at Joe
Biden's shirt weird
dude the only reason why I even got to
[__] have to think about Joe Biden
being shirtless on the beaches because
of these people being obsessed with Joe
Biden's nudity what the [__] is wrong
with you people it makes Jesus Christ
man I mean dude he made he made claims
about kovid being used to rig the 2024
election he made statements about uh
about how everyone was coming after him
he made statements about a slow Bill bar
going on Fox News he made statements
about oh I mean dude I I [__] go into
most of these because a lot of it's
repeat of him be like oh uh Jack Smith
and and Fanny Willis and all this other
stuff but the one that he repeats again
and again is the interview that he did
with Tucker Carlson he goes the he
basically says the poll numbers are in
and they're huge they're huge phone
numbers bigger interview numbers with
Tucker Carlson then the primary
Republican nominee you know like debate
the way we did way better 11 million to
261 million here's the thing it's not
261 million narrator truth the truth is
it's actually like 15 million votes or
15 million views on Twitter not
Impressions because Impressions is
anything and it's also the fact that uh
that Elon Musk pushed it right out onto
everyone's feed wow so it would be seen
by as many people as possible how much
money do you think Tucker Carlson pays
Elon Musk to do that
uh I don't know honestly because when I
think about money that would come back
to him Tucker Carlson only
sold
3 000 copies of his latest book that he
did and he did not purchase enough
copies to get on the New York uh New
York Times bestseller list what wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
are you telling me we're supposed to
believe the most popular famous biggest
of all time
a commentator on the right yeah Fox News
is gonna go down the drain because
Tucker Carson was fired Tucker Carlson's
gonna beat Fox News out of the
other that guy couldn't couldn't get on
the New York Times bestseller list nope
he did not have the RNC did not it's
almost like that's all a bunch of
[__] yeah it is it did not have Fox
like they had none of these things
available to them to purchase the books
to get themselves on the list it's why
it's the only reason that people like
Don Jr are able to get on the New York
Times bestseller list is because they
have the financial backing of the RNC to
pot to buy these books as party favors
for people at at different conventions
parties do you think do you think anyone
actually takes there's like stacks of
books everywhere yeah tons of books like
you want one like not really I I
wouldn't be do they even [__] read do
they even don't read I wouldn't be
surprised if these books were in storage
somewhere or if these were the very
books that that people were burning
because they're like this is they're in
boxes and Vagina Town all these books
are in storage in vagina town it's
Vagina Town that's where they're at
where they don't speak the Chinese they
only speak the Chinese in Vagina Town
that's where the box that's where the
books are stored I almost guarantee it
yeah it's in it's in someone's closet
somewhere it's in some storage unit in
in janetan it's in some other place and
or like I said a moment ago I'm you know
who knows who knows they might have
actually burned the books
it could be it could be they could burn
the books well we'll stay on top of this
story we'll figure out if Donald Trump's
gonna give another 31 31 videos why 31
what what I don't know how many how many
outtakes how many how many didn't make
the cut
that is a question I pose in the what
was that is how many of these ramblings
do we never see
how many of these ramblings and these
Rants and these tirades is Walt NADA
telling Donald Trump that he pressed the
record button for and Donald Trump's
like okay let's do it well stay tuned
because you're not going to want to miss
I'm sure we'll play that what was that
once it's complete here on air on the
Tony Michaels podcast so don't forget to
subscribe here at the Tony Michaels
podcast go to the Tony michaels.com find
us everywhere find Gabe Sanchez's
YouTube channel there as well if you
want to watch what was that on his
YouTube channel I just passed 7 000
subscribers this morning holy moly so
get get to the Tony michaels.com scan
all the way down you will find the link
for Gabe Sanchez's YouTube channel there
you're not going to want to miss what
was that also thank you for all the
venmo chats today
and also don't forget to go over to the
Discord that's right get over to the
Discord everyone's liking the Discord
chant over there they're like this place
is [__] awesome and that's because
it's kind of like no holds bar [__] I'm
fam over there and it's where the chat
party never stops it's where it never
stops so go to the Tony michaels.com
find all the leaks there follow us on
Twitch Facebook all the places download
every single episode you can find all
the links on the Tony michaels.com grab
me some [__] merch there as well
until tomorrow remember bonehead of the
week's tonight tomorrow's Friday so
we're gonna go over bone in the leech
don't forget to vote YouTube and Twitter
go to the Johnny michaels.com find those
links tomorrow same time same
[__] place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn headass Beacon